[Music]
hello there and welcome back you know
for a channel called monster maze I
think it's about high time we take a
look at an actual well maze the low male
labyrinths found in bref the wild a
total of three can be found across
Hyrule loam a labyrinth island Northland
a labyrinth and South loam a labyrinth
all of course built by the zone I
because it's ridiculous okay all kidding
aside though I'm not getting into the
lore behind these locations who built
them or why but rather look at these
landmarks on a mechanical level how they
function how they could be improved if
of course they make a return in the
sequel one fun little tidbit is that the
word loam a is actually an anagram for
the wards meadow meaning maze in
Japanese and in the English language
labyrinth is synonymous with maze so
basically these places are called maze
maze nice in actuality a maze and a
labyrinth are not the same thing
historically a labyrinth is a complex
pattern that only has one way to the
center without any branching and thus
there's no navigational challenge to
them however the terms are used
interchangeably nowadays when I first
stumbled across these massive landmarks
I was pleasantly surprised since it
stands out from the other shrine quests
found in the overworld if you've ever
seen The Maze Runner you know exactly
what I'm talking about
the idea of entering a large complex
maze having to map it out and find your
way around is an appealing thought so
let's see how these places fare against
some scrutiny shall we in my first draft
of this script I complained about the
aesthetics of these places it is very
bland and repetitive but then I figured
this isn't really a fair assessment it's
a maze after all the whole point of a
maze is to make you feel disoriented by
having each hallway and corridor look
the same it's harder to keep track of
where you've been and in this regard
these places definitely do succeed I
spent more time roaming these hallways
than I care to admit
each labyrinth has its own little quirk
lomi labyrinth island has a large
central room with a Guardian stalker
patrolling it and Guardian sky watchers
guarding the upper perimeter
additionally after you obtain the
barbarian helm from the shrine you gain
access to a basement section filled with
decayed Guardians some of which are
still active there's even one
incapacitated Guardian just laying
around one of the hallways north lomi
labyrinth is flipped 45 degrees on its
side and uses malice to halt your
progression it's also filled to the brim
with Rattlers elf lows and South Loma
labyrinths also has malice but there are
no enemies to fight inside only tuba
Carlin's are patrolling the outer wall
additionally it also makes use of a lot
of clothes off sections that cannot be
seen from above speaking of which I
think this is one of the aspects that
undermines the challenge a fair bit the
fact that you can see the structure of
the maze on your map while I was playing
through North lomi labyrinth I abuse
this quite a bit when you first enter it
you can immediately see the shrine
behind a set of bars the left path is
blocked by a significant amount of
malice first I explored all of these
hallways right here and got nowhere so I
pulled up my map and started connecting
the dots I know the shrine is right here
so I figured there has to be an entrance
to this room somewhere around this main
area since I already explored this
section the entrance has to be somewhere
around here
right so I climbed up to the top of the
maze which if you have enough stamina to
work with is actually pretty easy to do
and then from the top I navigated to the
location where I was guessing the
entrance had to be then I used the
paraglider to drop down and lo and
behold there it is in that regard south
lo mein labyrinth at least fares a
little bit better
since most of its corridors are
invisible from satellite view it doesn't
even really look like a maze on the map
as opposed to the other two I wondered
why not implement the same technique
they used with the sand storms in Gerudo
desert where your map function is
blocked as soon as you enter the area I
guess even the sheikah slate can deal
with bad reception of course you could
still cheat the system by prematurely
taking a picture with your phone before
you actually enter it but at least you
won't be able to see your current
location a different end /
HAP's more easy solution would be to
just have these structures show up as a
solid square or a rectangle on your map
now some people might actually enjoy the
fact that they have access to a map as
for me I would have rather used
different methods to navigate my way
through for instance by leaving a
breadcrumb trail to know which corridors
I already visited at the very least your
map should fill in as you progress
through in my opinion as for being able
to climb up and cheat the system just
well put a roof on it I get that they
wanted you to see this massive structure
from afar and be like wow what is that
putting a roof on it would take that
experience away to a certain extent in
that case they could have used something
else like a force field that activates
when you get closer to the maze if they
repeat something like this in breath the
wall - I think one of the better options
would be to have these kinds of
challenges underground one of my
favorite things from Twilight Princess
are these random caves that you can find
in the overworld
they branch out almost like the root of
a tree and some of them actually go on
pretty far last year I went to an
underground salt mine
together with my friend Conrad from the
Commonwealth realm and one of the most
exciting feelings was the fact that you
genuinely feel like you are in an
underground network of tunnels that lead
every which way if the lights go out
down here finding your way around would
be quite the challenge actually we have
seen darkness used as a tool to
disorient the player in divine beast
Varadhan yeah and even better ty flow
ruins by the way if you haven't seen
NBC's video on that topic yet what are
you doing with your life go watch it
it's amazing walking around in
pitch-black darkness with nothing but a
torch to light your way is a nice touch
maybe not as dark as in breath the wild
perhaps a little bit more draw distance
would be better now in terms of music I
think it's fitting that they reuse the
same track from the last woods after all
the original Japanese name for the Lost
Woods in the Legend of Zelda on NES was
maze woods coincidence
yes but fitting either way and now onto
the final aspect and perhaps one of the
most important ones at that when it
comes to exploration the rewards in the
form of loot and treasure the most
obvious reward is of course the three
pieces of the barbarian set which by
itself already makes it worth the effort
however as you saw
with my example of cheating north lomi
labyrinth you can totally ignore large
parts of the maze itself just to obtain
this piece of apparel it would be nice
to also get rewarded for exploring the
rest of the area and in this regard the
labyrinth definitely do not disappoint
North lomi labyrinth holds a total of
nine treasure chests as well as some
weapons shields and some luminous stones
that can be found just laying around
many of the chests hold fabulous rewards
most notably a diamond edge of duality
knight's shield gold and silver rupee
and three chests with topaz a sapphire
and a ruby one cool thing I also found
was this little campsite in one of the
hallways near the outer wall apparently
someone else already tried to find our
way through before you did and had to
set up camp when they got lost there's a
barrel a pile of wood used to make a
campfire and what seems to be the
decayed remains of a tent he or she even
set up this little flag as some sort of
a waypoint
pretty neat lomi labyrinth island is
also quite generous a total of eight
treasure chests and again some other
stuff just scattered around the rewards
are once again pretty good and makes it
worth the trouble of searching every
nook and cranny as opposed to just going
straight for the shrine as mentioned
before after beating the shrine itself
you gain access to an extra basement
level which rewards you with a diamond
circlet which is a fantastic reward
south Lommel labyrinth is a little less
generous but this is understandable as
it is the smallest and least complex it
houses a total of four treasure chests
holding a gold and silver rupee a garuda
shield and a Garuda scimitar there's
also a golden Claymore and bow sticking
out from a pool of malice it's great to
see that these locations reward
additional exploration all in all in
breath the wild aloma labyrinths granted
a nice change of pace when it came to
the shrine quests most of these quests
were tied to riddles the labyrinth stood
out together with tight flow ruins and
the survival trial uneven tied on event
I'd I have no idea how to pronounce the
name of that place other than that there
isn't much to say about the lomi
labyrinths except that they were cool
kinda some have suggested that perhaps
we will revisit them or are given a new
purpose in breath the wall to which yeah
I guess that could be a possibility
however they would have to add some
new to them like a new section on the
ground perhaps thanks a lot for watching
I hope the hours of me mindlessly
wandering these hallways brought you
some entertainment as a tease for the
next subject we will be looking further
into the aspect of darkness however this
time it's not gonna be a Zelda game but
rather a series that I also hold very
dear to me if you came to this channel
for the Zelda content fear not I will
still make comparisons between next
week's subject and the Zelda series and
who knows if you haven't played any of
the games in this series you might even
be swayed to pick one up sometime and of
course more Zelda stuff will be on the
way after this one as always if you like
my content consider subscribing hitting
the bell and all that good jazz or maybe
spread the video around a little bit if
you feel like it oh this is dawn signing
off and have a good one
North Loma North North lomé elaborate
North's loam a labyrinth